(in some deep voice, speaking japanese)
*grunt* i'm sorry
uh i dunno the word here, pls help me future caption editors i'm not fluent okay thanks
(in some deep voice, speaking japanese)
uh i dunno the word here pls help me future caption editors i'm not fluent okay thanks
AHOGHUAHOO
Master, please forgive me
These are the words spoken by some of the most powerful people that we know
before they go absolute savage beast mode
PewDiePie said it
omg pewds you are secretly naruto kun  im suing
(song)  BUT I MUST GO ALL OUT,  JUST THIS ONCE
That kid that had God and anime on his side
I HAVE THE POWER OF GOD AND ANIME ON MY SIDE
ḑ̹͈̽̏͐̇̇̔̅è̫̞m̴̥̒ͩo̬ͥ͑̆̆̚n͛̈́̂̔̋͑ĩ͓͚̭̾͡c̱͖̰ͧ́ ͇̞͑͌ͨ̐͠c͕̰̓̓r̞͉̩̥͓̄i̘͓̙͈͐̊ẽ͊̊͑ͤ̈͂s͙̤̳̜͇̮̎͒̀̚ͅ ̛͔͚̈́ͤ͆o͎͌͆͒̅ͮ̅̊f̶͕͓̬̭̝̓̓̌̍ ̳̫̩̔ͥ̃p̹̠͉̙̗͕̽ͬ̓̈́ͪͣ̈́a͚̝̳̓̕ͅî͖̫ͥ̉̓ͅͅn̻̖
̥ͮ̅͆
We're here to review some of the other
utmost powerful people on the planet
These G O D S that walk amongst us
That are holding back their strength
Just to not destroy the earth
In one fatal blow
L E T' S      G O
Let's get into it
"This time it's personal
*Teleports behind you*
ᴡʜᴇʀᴇ ᴀʀᴇ ᴍʏ ᴛᴇsᴛɪᴄʟᴇs"
*felix laughs*
You do it to the wrong dog,
That's so cute as well *laugh*
Edgar would never do that,
He's completely useless.
BUT YOU DO IT TO THE WRONG DOG.
And one day, after years of training..
He'll get you back
He'll take back what's rightfully yours
WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
wHAT DO YOU MEAN YOU STILL DON'T HaVE THEM?
bUT wHERE aRe tHEy??
dID YOu sTEaL ThEM AwAY??
Oh god
(pewds is possessed by the spirit of shaggy)
You made me use one per-
THIS IS A [hecking] SPOILER, [heck] OFF
Forget it, nothing happenned
"Legally I can kill him, Queen confirms"
MY GAWD
The queen really is, truly a figure
That has not released her full potential yet
Just wait, when she dies...
Big Ben is just gonna fckin ExpLOde
"I am sorry, master"
No Sasuke,
not this time
Please DJ Khaled...
Spare me...
Who the [heck] made this?
STOP SPOILING ON MY FAVOURITE ANIME
To conquer fear, one must become fear
My god
I mean, that makes sense
*laugh*
The R is ambitious, I gotta give it to them
The best part about this is I
can't tell if he's trolling or not
*Hehehe*
You know what would be really cool?
Like in photoshop, if you like, crop me out,
And then you make sure you add the stroke effect
And then the outer glow layer effect
OK??
aND THEN ADD THAT -
*has a stroke*
GRAFITTI FONT
On FEAR
OOh my god
"When you're on your way out and realise
you have dressed as the punisher"
(P.S. Not real guns)"
Oh, thank god
I bet they are real (what a bad boy)
I bet he's ready to strike at any moment
Punish me daddy,  (m-marzia)
This is some real tuesday material, man
"Peppa must go all out.... Just this once"
Peppa, it is time
Change of plans
I'm afraid that won't be possible..
So be it
*laugh*
Peppa the pig!
You're losing the battle.
Only 15% of women in the US call themselves feminists
OH
This guy is heading up with facts
And logic
Ok *explosion*
Only 7% in the UK.
Just give up.
Your cult has no purpose anymore,
And it's running on fumes
All aboard the Trump train!
Oh god,
I hope this is trolling. (me too)
If it's trolling, it's A+
It's just a tiny sword as well (just-just like my-)
Legit, I have bigger sword (and I oop-)
Ok?
Nobody:
Pewdiepie: I have a bigger sword, somewhere
ᴰᴼᴺ'ᵀ heck ᵂᴵᵀᴴ ᴹᴱ
ᴵ ᴴᴬᴠᴱ ᵀᴴᴱ ᴾᴼᵂᴱᴿ ᴼᶠ ᴳᴼᴰ ᴬᴺᴰ ᴬᴺᴵᴹᴱ ᴼᴺ ᴹʸ ˢᴵᴰᴱ
s͙͝c̊̐̄ͩ̒r̢̜͇̤͎̼͔̻̃e̡̥̤̋ͫâ̻̥̥͙̾̍m̺̝̠͎̘̫̆͊s̀̋ͦ̾ͭ̌͌ ̮͉̯̺͔͙͛ͨ̓̓̔̌̎o̻̬͍̗̳̘͂ͪͮͦf̺̰̼̫̉̋̄̆̅̃ͥ͞ ̶̱̭̣͙͙̻ą̙̻̣̘̘̹̞͐̓̓̏̍ͦ ̛̟̹̝̘̰̩̽̅ͯͦt̺̣̺̫̹͑ͬō̞͙͈͍̥͐̂̆̃ͅͅr̖̺̝͓̣̙͌̇̑͑́m̡͓̂̚ĕ̘͇̯̭̼̼̮̓̄n̴̤͕̳̱͛ͅt͔̰̝̰̜͚̩̄͑ͨͨ͒̈̚e̢͕͐d̥̣̭̹̟͊ͦ̄̓̋ ̵̩̖͙͍̾ͨͯͮw͈̿̓̾͊͟a̜̰͚̭̣̾ͫ̈́̍ͮ̇r̭̉̀̾ͥ̔́r̫̥̝̭̓̓̽i̺͉̣̯̝ͪ̽ͫͦ͆̂o̢͍̞ͦͤͤ͛ͬr̄͂̑̅ͥͥ
Hey guys, check out Justin Roland's new game
"Trover saves the universe"
it's very 𝖊𝖕𝖎𝖈
i legit can't see with these on
Let's see, leather jacket, cheap replica sword AND a cane.
oH hE SAid cANe
it's a frikin cane, i thought it was the holdster
kAPOOF
you think i'm not holding back my strength as well?
at any given moment, i can slice you into tiny pizza roll pieces >:(
o k a y ?
"garfield san: your greed for lasagna-filled onigiri has gone too far, you must be stopped.
hHA!"
(in some deep voice, speaking japanese)
iDioT
"I didn't feel a thing, john san!"
"Your kenjetsu has gotten weak.
N-NANI!? (W-WHAT!?)
*whispers* sαүσηαяα (ɠσσԃႦყҽ)
garfield san.."
where did this meme start from, i'm tryna track where this is like..
"it's a generic anime quote"
yeah, but everyone can relate to it, it HAS to have a source..
"it looks like the quote came from Naruto or Death note"
[hecking] CRINGE DUDE
yOU thiNK THey sAid thAT iN DEath noTe? yoU [hecking] diMWitTtED PieCE OF [poo-poo]
it's so st u p i d
"STOP! YOU'RE SURROUNDED. THERE'S NOWHERE TO RUN.. IT'S OVER!
master forgive me, but i must go all out... just this once"
*singing* BObs oR VAGana whiChevER- what happened to my voice?
jesus ✝, lord ✝, almighty lord ✝?
is it weird that i think those swords are cool? *laughs*
it looks like the fat kid who slices the.. fat. sword. guy.
there it is, that's all you need.
will keith... look at this dood, this guy knows his work, this guy knows his strength.. my god..
he's doing real big. my god the prECisioN.. soMEOne stOP THis mAN.. oOOOOH MY gAAAAAAAWD
WATch oUT wAtEr bOTTLE-
*screaming* OOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOW?
*screaming*
HOW?
*̵̮̙s̸̱̝̥͚̊̾ͯ͆̂̑c͖͍̜ͦͬ̊̎̑͂ͤr̷̫̗̱̞̼̦̮ͩ̓e̷̯͖͉ͫ̎̿ͤ̂ͭa̢̦̯̫͇͂͌̽̔ͅm̵͉̜͉ͬ̅ͥ̍i͎̱͖ͣ́ͯ̓̕n̠͍̫̑̂͗ͪͭ̾͞ͅg͕̪̝̟̳̞̣ͯ̑ͯ̾ͫ̉͑ ͑͐̄̒i̧͇͉̤̝̳̺ͣ̽̐̑͛̈́ń͉t̛͒͑͒eͤ͞n̨̻̭͈̭̭̾ͬͦs̵̪̣̰̠̗͒͛ͩ̀͐̌͗i̤̝̱̘̭̿̋̐ͨ̈́ͪ̒f͓̦̖̥̗̟͚̍̿͗i͕̮̖͙͍̒͐̈́̑ͭ̌͒̀ḛ̸̘̘̺̯ͦ͆̿ͨs͈̱ͫ̓ͯ͆*ͦͬ̾̌ͩͮ͏͕
*screaming* cAREFUL!
THAT'S A BIGGER THAN YOU ;0
*screaming*
HE STABS IT
oooH HE'S CHANGING BREATH (????) (it's grip, you're welcome - Alicia)
that's a pricive stab right there
dem multiple criticals!
he's going for the finiSHIIIIIIING-
*screams*
*pure amazement*
the hair and the face doesn't matter, nothing can stop this man.
except ριȥȥα ɾoʅllʂ
мαɴy pιzzα rollѕ
"the man obviously doesn't like water"
"he could single handily take down ISIS"
"Jesus Christ, that's Jason Bourne."
"I came here when searched for `fat katana guy`"
you got fat sword guy *chuckles*
he's dope, alright? i don't care
you don't understand his strength
you don't understand his POWER
iT CAn't bE COntaiNed
"My true power is limited by my 30 ton boots."
holy sh.. he's got MY boots!
i'm beginning to get a pathup here that's i'm not really sure if i like it?..
"While you were out there eating trash, i was studying the blade"
*chuckles*
raccoons are so awesome
they're cute as edible (wha??)
you know, this sword has been relived in my family through many generations
my great grandfatha..
i wish i had a cool story like that ;(
but, i don't..
oH MY GOD
*laughing*
th.. those... "those are her victims in the background"
*ehEEHehEEH*
"this is a different version of you know i had to do it to em"
*laughter*
nanna gascoine
NANNA GASCOIGNE
the meme just got better and better
"her health bar is er..." giNORMOUS
WE HAVE THE SAME FCKING SWOOORD :D
this sword was given to me by nanna gascoine *laughter*
to be fair, like, this is actually a dope sword
it's got shark skin
At least I'm told it was shark skin
It was apparently used by
*stutters* See I am what I'm making fun of
I am aware of that at least
It was used in World War .. I think World War I
They still had swords in World War I I think
Did they have swords in World War I
You run out of ammo, thats when you go Sensei
*speaks Japanese*
Patrick come on
Forgive meh
Here it is the classic the meme that started it all
"While you were watching Hentai, I was studying
the car. *slight skratta*
While you were yelling at your mom to make pizza--
PIZZA ROLLS!
*laughs*
I knew that was the reason I thought of pizza rolls
*skratta*
While you were yelling at your mom to make pizza rolls, *low voice* I was studying...
The car.
While you were trying to find a girlfriend on online forums,
I was studying The car
Now that it's making that weird squeking noise,
you have the audacity to come to me for help?
Now, in your time of need?
that's when you come to me?
my god, someone stop him
he's being controlled by the dog..
why is there a goddamn dog in his shirt?
this is so confusing
and so badass..
HE'S RUNNING OUT OF PAPER TOWELS!
H U R R Y U P !
u want a paper towel?
and then your just gonna have to come for me boi
Master, forgive me
HOLY WHAT?
it's Blade and sorcery?
*Y E E T*
wait, its that VR game?
did they update?--
YOU CAN DO THAT??
I NEED TO PLAY IT AGAIN!
THAT'S AWESOME!
so let me tell you guys the story of how I lost my happiness
I lost my debate today, when I very clearly should've won
this is my whole life, my whole purpose, ruined by an unfair bias.
I feel cheated, I feel robbed, I feel like I may not be so good at debating.
anyway, that's all, download tuber simulator, it's free and it's fun and it's like running your own company pretty much
pretty good if you're a control freak who wants to start their own business one day.
so go, gamers. get that practice bread and prosper.
join my network it's called 'The Ladies'
please we need funding
please